le petit centre commercial du quartier
des grands-champs ce serait bien passé
de cette fermeture
l'une après l'autre les boutiques
baissent leurs rideaux et la disparition
du bureau de poste est un nouveau coup
dur notamment pour les personnes âgées
ici c'est l'épicier du coin qui a repris
l'activité postale colis recommandés
d'arbres mais pour tous les regrets sont
vivaces
il n'y a pas grand chose aux branches
ont déjà ses traits voilà c'était très
limité on a tous faire la presse il ya
pu y avoir il ya beaucoup de choses où
c'est dommage fermé officiellement
depuis ce matin sa disparition
représente pour beaucoup la fin d'une
époque où le quartier était bien plus
vivant
c'est toujours été ma poste et il ya une
entreprise dans la région c'est là que
je venais très pratique les filles 13
jan aps le fal personnel très gentil et
donc c'est un peu regrettable que ce
cerveau il publie ce pack wii beaucoup
très regrettable comme tout ce qui ferme
d'ailleurs désormais il faudra se rendre
en centre ville pour effectuer les
opérations financières
à moins que les négociations menées
entre la poste et la municipalité ne
permettent de trouver un moyen de
substitution